what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay
so picking up with the epilogue to
Spider Island this is actually really
kind of cool the whole base is from what
I can tell anyway the whole basis behind
Spider Island was really kind of like
what the early bit of Dance Lots run was
leading up to and the since there was
this idea the dance floor looked around
I said there's a lot of things in the
spider-man mythos I don't really care
for there was done by committee because
room Berg when Dan Slott first became
part of this writing committee after the
events of one more day it was everybody
is going to be part and parcel to this
you know there's going to be there's a
lot of fingers in this story that's
being told it wasn't just Dan Slott
doing what Dan Slott wanted to do but
having the ability to take over the
title on his own and do whatever it is
that he wanted to do granted him the
opportunity to say okay let's just clear
out all the stuff I don't like let's get
rid of all the things I don't want that
I don't want to have in the spider-man
net though let's rectify all this stuff
and that's exactly what happens here but
it also sends out some threads for
future stories that will come later on
down the line specifically superior
spider-man so what we do is you
basically just kind of pick up with the
aftermath I mean a story is called naked
city and it's kind of funny here I mean
it's all these different superheroes in
the in the Marvel Universe who were all
giant spiders you know during the events
of Spider Island and it's kind of funny
here you know because it's like
everybody's kind of recovering and I
buddy shocked that they were naked the
only person who doesn't care is Hercules
and Hercules is like yes look upon my
beseech with envious eyes male
superheroes it's it's really kind of
this funny situation that's one of the
things I love so much about his
character because he's just kind of like
I'm in my natural form like I am
urgently you know I am the god of
strength they don't call me a giant for
no reason and it's uh in all seriousness
it's just one of these funny little when
we funny little things again it's just
kind of it's really just cleanup you
know it's just it's cleaning things up
getting things sorted out getting things
back in order and so the idea here is
that we pick out with Mary Jane Watson
and Peter Parker and this is one of the
things is kind of cool because Dan Slott
sort of takes its moment between the two
of them and it's not really Dan Slott
saying hey we're going to get them back
together again
it's Dan Slott saying hey these two
share a connection that no one else
really shares and that's true you know
even within the the spider-man mythos
that's true you know the fact that they
dated for so long she was one of the
first people to know about his secret
identity so on and so forth but
item of the comic we as the reader look
at that and it's like even if they're
only really good friends for us is the
reader for people who followed
spider-man there's a connection between
the two of them that no one else has the
stories that have been written about
Mary Jane Watson about Peter Parker have
had their ups and downs they've been
married they broke up but their marriage
was nullified by Mephisto there's all
kinds of things that go on with their
story and so a lot of people look at
that and say look at the legacy that was
forged between these two and it's really
Dan Slott kind of pointing at that it
stands out saying hey they're showing a
rooftop moment and it represents
everything as they've been through up to
this point the other half of this is
that in the middle of the conversation
Peter Parker just basically has to bail
out because you know Aunt May's grabbing
his attention when she and Jay jonah
Jameson senior are finally making their
way off to Boston officially leaving New
York after the events of Spider Island
and this is when we learned that Mary
Jane Watson retained her spider powers
it was really kind of cool you know to
ask the question what kind of stories
are we going to see but again this whole
idea of anti-venom you know for example
the idea that Eddie Brock was looking
for atonement for his past acts when he
was a villain comes to fruition when
Reed Richards pops up on TV now again
keep in mind when it comes to the moral
landscape Reed Richards how he's viewed
within Marvel Comics as how he is how
he's viewed outside of Marvel Comics
within the Marvel Comics universe it's
like Reed Richards one of the smartest
men in the world everybody respects him
he's an explorer the superheroes love
them when it comes to us as readers
outside of comics just like the
Fantastic Four the first family of
marble the Fantastic Four set the
groundwork for the Avengers force with
all these different teams that would
come later on down the line
you know guardians of the galaxy they
were the template behind that the legacy
characters and so when Reed Richards
shows up on TV and says New York were
saved because of the actions of Eddie
Brock well they may be Brock's a good
guy now and there's no arguing that
point it's just the way it is and it's
really cool because that's the kind of
kind of respect that Reed Richards
commands from people in New York from
the superhero community so on and so
forth but again it's just kind of
wrapping up a few loose ends here you
know in the sense that Jay jonah Jameson
having a drink with Robbie Robertson
again they're kind of on a kind of on
different terms here in terms of you
know Jay jonah Jameson being mayor of
New York Robbie Robertson running
frontline now but it's also this idea
that Jay jonah Jameson still doesn't
seem to want to give up the notion that
Peter Parker that bit spider-man saved
the city he kind of wants to hang on to
his anger hang on to his hatred for all
this and at the end of the day Robbie
Robertson says dude you've got to give
spider-man a Blake you know he was
basically the key to saving the city
he's one of the
oh that helped save the entirety of the
city so in the end you know Jay John
Jameson's like fine I'll give them a
break
you know I will I'll cut them a break
I'll make a call and we'll see what
happens you know we have Peter Parker
helping some guys on the bridge you know
get things cleared up you know get
things cleared out it's just kind of
this cool little moment the problem is
that after Peters done saying his
goodbyes to Aunt May after she and Jo
Jameson leave for Boston he gets back
home to the apartment Carly Cooper and
this is really where Dan Slott begins to
sort of wrap things up between the two
because Carly Cooper's breaking up with
it now this is what I said it was
important that we had to keep in mind
the whole idea of Peter Parker going on
TV and saying I'm spider-man you know
during the events of Spider Island
because Carly Cooper has figured out his
secret identity and that was not
supposed to happen remember it's almost
like those is like the Harry Potter
universe right you know when those
wizards of stuff cast a spell somebody
walks up to something that I supposed to
walk up to and then suddenly they
remember they're supposed to go do
something else
the spell is much like that that dr.
strange I cast in the sense that unless
Peter Parker went to Carly Cooper and
said you know took off his mask and said
hey look I'm spider-man or revealed his
identity to who and what to her
individually or she just walked up on
him while he was changing into his
spider-man costume she's not supposed to
know no one is supposed to know but she
knows and what she says is I'm a
forensic scientist my job is to put the
pieces together and what she says is
when Spider Island happened and I was
getting my spider powers for the first
time and everybody in the city was
getting their spider powers for the
first time you were the only one that
knew exactly how to use them you were
the only one that slid right into the
role and knew it perfect and she even
goes back if you guys remember with
volume 1 in Big Time she goes back and
says when we were hanging out not was
showing you how to roller-skate you
didn't know how to roller-skate you were
trying to figure it out she was like
that's what you should have done when
you were tricking me and that's that's
the biggest issue for her is not that
Peter Parker spider-man it's the fact
that he lied to her with Carly Cooper
her family's mired in deceit
her family's mired in people keeping
their own secrets with her going to
Peter Parker when they first started
getting together her her her whole thing
was you better know what you're doing
and you better not lie and Peter Parker
lied to her duped her about his identity
now granted this was done by Peter for
the safety of all I mean that was
something that was established during
the events of civil war that was the
whole crux when Peter Parker went on
stage during the events of civil war and
said hey everybody my name is Peter
Parker I'm revealing my identity because
I trust iron man when he says
superheroes who come forward and
registered with shield will not have to
worried about their family being put in
danger that was exactly what happened as
soon as Peter Parker revealed his
identity he walked out people tried to
attack him they tried to attack Aunt May
they tried to attack Mary Jane Watson
and so in response to this when civil
war was over when it was all said and
done after the events of one more day
and all that kind of good stuff when
Peter Parker went to dr. strange you
know when the post-civil war landscape
and said I want to make sure no one
knows what my identity is Doctor Strange
cast a spell and it was done to make
sure that if Peter Parker for some
reason his identity was dumped out that
he wouldn't have to worry about that he
would have to worry about people
figuring out who he is he wouldn't have
to worry about his friends and family
being put in danger the issue with all
this is that for Carly Cooper it just
doesn't it doesn't resonate
she just doesn't grasp it at the end of
the day she's just like you lied to me
and so ultimately she says we're done
we're over with now what follows this is
actually kind of weak to be honest it's
actually kind of a weak way to do this
what dr. strange when Peter Parker goes
to dr. strange and says why does she
know my secret identity no one was
supposed to know what in the heck
happened dr. strange says when you went
on TV and told people I'm Peter Parker I
have spider powers you basically told
everybody you were spider-man you undid
the spell or at least didn't really undo
it but make it weaker make it possible
for people to know who he was
it's not like he was running your
spider-man mask and went on TV like he
did during civil war take his mask off
and say I'm spider-man but it was almost
the same thing and because that did
weaken dispel to a degree and people can
start figuring out his identity now this
was basically Dan Slott coming back and
saying okay let's get things sorted out
let's make things reasonable let's set
this for the purpose of making
spider-man stories a little more
dangerous because that was always kind
of an intrinsic value of Peter Parker
stories someone somewhere may figure out
his identity and if they do what happens
like that was always kind of the basis
behind it so it was basically beeping up
the number of people in his groans
gallery who could know who he is taking
it beyond jackal you know getting into
all these different individuals and
setting the stage for superior
spider-man and so what we end up doing
is we sort of transition to this last
little bit of a send-off with Madame web
again you know Julia carpenter Madame
web being able to see the future and so
on I should really just kind of sit down
with with Peter and she says look you
know what you are given here is a chance
to basically start over you know you
were given or you had this last little
vial of the Cure from max Modell if you
take this it will cure you of your
spider powers
you will no longer be spider-man you
will be Peter Parker and you will be
able to live a regular life she says the
web of life in destiny
chooses avatars for the totem your
spider-man because the web of life and
destiny chose you to be spider-man if
you walk away someone else can take your
place it could be Ben Riley
it could be Kayne Parker it could be any
number of people it could be a random
guy off the street it's her basically
saying you have an out and have a chance
to walk away this is Dan Slott toying
with the notion that Peter Parker might
not be spider-man anymore but in the end
he says no he says I'm going to stay
spider-man I'm going to be spider-man of
course we would have a hard time
envisioning a scenario where Peter
Parker was never spider-man again I have
a hard time imagining a situation where
mama would release a story where Peter
Parker on the main Marvel Universe where
it's like Peter Parker is never going to
be spider-man again like this is going
to be somebody else like they kill off
Peter Parker and replace him with Miles
Welles that'll never happen it's like
eliminating Superman and having him gone
forever and never bringing him back in
the end Peter Parker's and legacy
character is he's so significant to the
success of Marvel Comics and one of
their best-selling titles if that
happened they'd be on the verge of
destroying their entire comic book line
just because of one individual person is
a bold statement but is the same think
it's actually pretty accurate here and
so in the end we pick up with Mary Jane
Watson and this was kind of a cool thing
is because Peters also learning that
Mary Jane still has her powers to a
degree but it's also kind of reconciling
these two things and even then you know
he sits down and he talks with Mary Jane
about how Peter you know how he and
Carly has basically broken up now again
Dan Fox kind of 20 here he's like well
maybe will they get together won't they
get together and we're really not given
an answer here we're really not given an
answer on whether or not the two of them
will end up getting back together again
instead the conversation kind of
deviates towards the idea that Peter
Parker feels like well his actions will
just go unnoticed
that'll just be another instance of
Peter saving the city and no one will
really care that much for Mary Jane
Watson says now the Empire State
Building has been lit up in celebration
of you your colors it's the city of New
York saying thank you it's the city of
New York basically saying thank you
spider-man
for saving our city for keeping us alive
and it is cool it's a really great way
because what this does is basically wrap
up like the first half of dance class 1
the first part of dance watch 1 it's
been clearing all that stuff out and
saying okay guys now we basically get to
start over again
now we officially get into what it is
that I wanted to do now we officially
get into everything leading up into
superior spider-man going into
spider-verse going into all-new
all-different amazing spider-man all
that kind of good stuff
so what I being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end if you're new
here the comments explained make sure
you hit some button to become part of
the robb
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later
[Music]